love for me is about the heart  and the way that i view life everything  is a blessing  [Applause]  he just keeps getting hotter yum  everything you shared are the qualities  that i'm looking for in my wife  all my worst insecurities are coming out  i just have to hope that it's worth it  the bachelor premieres january 4th on  abc  love for me is about the heart and  the way that i view life everything is a  blessing  [Applause]  he just keeps getting hotter yum  everything you shared are the qualities  that i'm looking for in my wife  all my worst insecurities are coming out  i just have to hope that it's worth it  the bachelor premieres january 4th on  [Music]  abc